we're coming back to you live from
Helsinki Finland late at night Sun
rising anyway of course this was the
site of the Vladimir Putin Donald Trump
summit earlier today just finished
back in Washington meanwhile former FBI
agent Lisa Paige returned to Capitol
Hill she has appeared to two House
committees behind closed doors to
deliver further testimony about her
behavior at the FBI over the last couple
of years when she and Peter struck
routinely sent highly political messages
to one another in one case promising to
derail the Trump campaign congressman
Darryl ISIL represents the state of
California he sits on the House
Judiciary Committee he heard Paige's
testimony today and he joins us tonight
congressman thank you very much for
coming on so what what can you tell us
about what Lisa Paige said well first of
all I was surprised how smart she is and
how poised she is she is one smart
attorney and and I say that not in any
way except to say she was much better
witness in her own Iran for her own
purposes very careful very poised what
we did see though is things like and I
can't speak to the questions and answers
as you can understand but yeah she would
look over and put her hand out for the
FBI a lawyer there to object any time
she saw an opening for that objection
she was literally prompting for those
and I found that to be pretty
reprehensible she no longer works for
them and it's not her job to determine
those so-called equities that are being
invented by the FBI as some sort of a
privilege now most of us have seen a
partial transcript of her text exchanges
with her boyfriend or former boyfriend
and so we have a pretty clear picture
for political views and the intensity of
those views give us a picture of her
involvement in the Russia investigation
how close to the center of that was she
how influential was she how meaningful
was her participation well this is
something that she said in general she
said constantly which is she kept
wanting to reduce her importance she
went on at length about how many people
changed between investigations and how
how there were too many other people for
for her per se to have had an influence
but let's remember Peter struck looked
at us and said he didn't have a bias he
didn't do anything but he had no answer
for why it was his computer that
downgraded Hillary Clinton's misuse from
a crime to an on crime literally the
that report was changed on his computer
so they were critical they were they
teamed up together and there really
wasn't an answer to that in any of her
testimony only an obfuscation of her
importance remarkable thank you very
much congressman for coming on and
giving us that window into it appreciate
it Thank You Tucker